this is my channel update for december
2013.
normally what i would do with these
these updates is talk quite a bit about
what i've done or what went on in the
last month and then talk about what i've
got coming up in the the next month but
what i want to do first before i talk
about last month is talk about
uh an event that i've got coming up
about a week from from today this month
something completely new for me i'm
going to be using a google hangout on
air to
do something that could turn into a
regular feature of this channel
namely i'm going to have a hangout where
i'll carry on some discussion or do some
some q a with some of my my viewers or
google plus followers
so in order to access that you'll need a
google plus account which i think you
can't really
sign up for youtube anymore without
getting one of those
and i will be posting information about
this on my my google plus
on
youtube also on my facebook page
and on
twitter and i'll also put stuff on
linkedin academia.edu
so
what i'm going to do for the first topic
i thought i wanted wanted to start out
with something that i
i know pretty well and have thought
quite a bit about so we're going to
focus it on socrates questions or
issues or comments that people have
related to this great
this great thinker socrates who spawns
plato so we could talk about the
socratic question we could talk about
um
the sort of influence that he had not
only on plato but on other thinkers like
antisthenes the founder of the cynics
later on you know it was
seen as a important figure for the
stoics
on the ceratic school
through aristippus so those are all
things that we could we could talk about
it'll be fairly open-ended and what i
will do beforehand is
actually solicit a set of questions so
that if if it's a slow start i've got
some some material to get going with
and it will be recorded and turned into
another youtube video so this is very
experimental it might be a complete flop
it might turn out to be something great
that i want to do more of
but we're going to give that a shot so
that is going to be
saturday the 14th of december 2013
and we'll
put some information about the exact
dates times and how to get involved with
that or how to at least view it while
it's going on a little bit later this
week
so november was a very busy month for me
um
i didn't get quite as many videos in in
some areas as i wanted to get done
you know in particular the
existentialist videos but i did get a
lot of other things accomplished
i did an insight radio
uh guest appearance on patrick mccarty's
show
and we talked we started out talking
about my work on aristotle and anger
i'm writing a book on on the topic right
now sort of bringing together
aristotle's theory of anger from a
number of different texts and then it
meandered off into a lot of different
discussions particularly about education
and about virtue ethics and moral
education and and what's going on with
that
i also did a talk
on the
seven deadly sins and how they started
out originally as the eight capital
vices
discussed by the desert fathers people
like a vegaris ponticus and then you
know coming through john cassian
and how did we how do we go from eight
to seven and and where did you know envy
get in the lot when it wasn't originally
there and what happened to sadness and
acadia and
you know
where how did pride and vainglory get
condensed into one as well so there's an
interesting story there i did a talk
about that you can see that
i'll put a link to it right about here
in in this uh this talk
my classes have been wrapping up at
marist college and so this is the month
when students begin to panic because
they see
what they've left undone and what they
haven't quite mastered that they would
have liked to
and
a lot of things are coming due not just
in my classes but especially in their
other classes and you know these kids
take five to six classes per semester
so
um and i think a lot of the the
professors kind of backload the the
grading and the the work i try to sort
of front load it so that they get a lot
of things done earlier in the semester
and they're not so stressed out by the
end but i'm dealing with with students
who are are busily accomplishing what
they need to accomplish and
trying to bring everything to a close
my my biggest interest is in seeing that
these students
will
finish the class
and then
five years down the line still retain
something from the class
so i've been doing a lot of stressing
you know how these these discussions
that we're having
actually apply to their life and it's
fairly easy to do with the ethics class
and i think also the intro class because
i focused it on on friendship desire and
love
so
i've been involved in quite a few
interesting projects that are gradually
taking shape there's there's a number of
different online platforms
that
are
set to do you know important
beta testing or releases to the general
public fairly soon and i'm getting
solicited by people who want to
bring me in
to
to do content for them to produce
classes
or at least portions of classes for them
uh mainly because i think of the youtube
uh video stuff because people are now
coming up to me at conferences and
saying oh you're that guy on my youtube
videos i knew i knew you from somewhere
so we're we're talking and when i say we
i mean uh my wife and i who are reason i
owe our consulting and content
production company
we're we're engaged in talks with a
number of different people about uh the
things that they want to do with their
their online platforms and how we would
fit in with that
um haven't started producing any content
for that but that's going to start
happening this month with with at least
one of them
so uh what else um videos i shot 10 core
concept videos
this month
some of them having to do with with kant
some of them having to do with aristotle
some of them having to do with the
ethics of care primarily rosemary tong
um
i think i might have done some jon
stewart mill once but that might have
been last month i did get one
existentialist video finally done on leo
chest off and i'm still shooting some
more on on him
i started doing a new series of videos
and these are i call these philoso geek
which is a term my wife actually made up
uh but it applies to us very well we're
both uh very very geeky about
learning about the humanities and about
philosophy in particular
and
you know i'm involved this is a prime
example through through youtube uh
connecting up with a lot of people and
sort of spilling content out into the
world and i call that the techno sphere
um
and you know you could call it all sorts
of other things if you wanted to as well
it doesn't just include the internet but
all of our engagement with the internet
and it you know it's affecting the way
we do education it's affecting the way
we do business
and
i've been getting more and more involved
with it because of doing these videos
and because of doing online classes and
generating content
so
i've been thinking a lot about
the transformations that are taking
place in our world
and in the ways in which we do business
and teach ethics and communicate with
each other
about family matters
uh you know it's everything across the
board the the techno sphere has become
part of our our
skeletons and organs so to speak you
know we we
move in it
and it ties in with us
in a lot of different ways which in some
some cases can be a little bit troubling
you know finding out what the nsa can
can easily call up about us or how much
of our data is being mined for
commercial uses
but you know it it's here to stay i
think unless unless the economy
completely shrivels up or we we run out
of fossil fuels and and
aren't able to find some some recourse
or you know some massive electromagnetic
magnetic pulse fries everything unless
that happens
we are living a a a life that's in this
radically new world which is not
something
um completely different from from what's
going on before i don't buy this thing
that like digital natives are a new
species or anything like that as a
matter of fact i think the digital
natives are not very good with
technology
uh
in comparison to you know generation x
who had to
learn how to to adapt themselves to it
that's a whole different conversation
in any case i'm shooting these new
videos uh you know philosophy geek
reflections on the technosphere and i
got started because
google
uh made some some boneheaded changes
uh that affected youtube and i started
thinking well you know i do a lot of
thinking and talking
with other people about
technology and education
and communication and what's going on so
i should start i should start shooting
videos on that i should start actually
uh engaging in that in a more thematic
systematic fashion so i've been doing
that um
i also shot seven course videos
and those are going to be the last
course videos from my
face-to-face classes that i shoot for a
while i think
right now you know there aren't going to
be any course videos
over over the
holiday break
but i'm even thinking that next semester
i might not
shoot those i'm teaching
different classes next semester and i'm
not sure that they're going to be
that well suited to uh to video
recording well i'll think about it
um
got a little bit of writing done this
this month on aristotle on the anger
book
i also
did something
fairly dramatic i put all my blogs
on hold
because i realized i just wasn't finding
the time to to actually get to blogging
so i
i always felt guilty about that at the
end of each week
and i took the suggestion that my my
wife had of actually biting the bullet
and
putting a message saying look i just
don't have the time for that sort of
stuff i'm doing a lot of stuff with
video production
and
online teaching so
this is gonna have to to go on hold for
a while
that's freeing me up to do not only more
video content stuff but to get back to
some of the academic writing that i want
to do writing papers for conferences
you know writing new articles taking
taking old conference papers and
previously submitted
papers uh and turning them into articles
and working on the book projects that i
have that i
really want to make some some progress
on
um
so that's all november what about what's
going on in december i've got a a few
events coming up um the youtube event
with the
the
hangout on air is is one um that'll be
again saturday the 14th
and if that goes well
then
i'll think about doing some more of
those
um i've got another theology matters uh
radio interview with with devin pellu
and that one is going to be talking
about david hume
so i think it's going to center
primarily on hume's dialogues on natural
religion which i've taught before and
you can see some videos that i've shot
from those class sessions
and hume was a
human was a very sophisticated
opponent of classical theism
particularly of christianity because he
was in a christian nation
and
he his his arguments are used still by
quite a few people
and i like hume but i think he's wrong
on a lot of counts and so we're going to
talk a bit about how people use him
and what's going on in his works and and
where he seems to be on the right track
and where he's sort of made some rather
arbitrary commitments of his own
um
so got that coming up
uh i am teaching a class starting in
mid december a four week intensive
online class for marist college in
ethics
i've done that before it's it's tough to
do over the winter break
requires about a good
besides the content production which
thankfully i can i can recycle some of
the
stuff from previous classes
um the grading and the forums take me a
good several hours each day to stay on
top of and the students are you know
a lot of work for them
but it's you know it's a four-week class
so it's got to be in that format i
actually use the videos that i shot in
previous classes so that my students
aren't just you know reading texts and
engaging with with each other through
forums but also
have a sense of you know what it's like
to be in a classroom and hear lectures
on that sort of stuff so i've got that
going on i'm prepping for my two classes
in the spring one of which is my ethics
class
i'm thinking right now i haven't decided
i'm thinking about doing what's called
flipping the classroom with that which
is having them
uh do the reading and and watch lecture
videos before coming to class and then
spending the class time doing some very
intensive
uh hands-on
uh exercises and engaging in in
discussions about you know how we would
apply this these these concepts
but i i'm not
not 100 committed to that yet the other
class that i'm teaching is religion in
american culture
and i'm debating about whether i want to
videotape that or not
it's a class that i used to teach quite
often
back in one of my my former positions
and it could be good to do it's you know
religious studies are really kind of a
weird mix of history
and
you know
focused uh focus on religion it's you
you're studying people's theology but
you're not studying it from any
particular faith commitment
so generally you're studying somebody
else's religious views that's what i
tell my students
some philosophy inevitably comes in
there some sociology
some
some art some music
it's a weird kind of mix and i'm not
sure if it's going to transition well
in terms of lecture
to to videos but i'll think about that
i can tell you this that as far as
videos go in december
now that i'm not in the classroom and
i'm just teaching online
that frees me up for for doing a bit
more video work so
the existentialism series i want to get
that i want to get some steam uh behind
me now and get some some you know
forward momentum on that so i'm i'm
going to do a few more chest off videos
um i'm finishing up with some of his
early work i'm doing penultimate
penultimate words and his his discussion
of the theory of knowledge uh this week
uh after that i'm going to turn to
heidegger there's a couple essays by
heidegger that i really want to get to
in in this um
krell version one of them is the letter
on humanism where he's responding to to
sart's
uh discussion
where he kind of used heidegger and
heidegger saying
i'm not really in as much agreement with
you as as you think
the other one that i really want to talk
about is the question concerning
technology that's that's a great essay
and i think it's really central to
understanding heidegger's
work
and then if i have time
i'm planning
on getting to
kierkegaard sickness on to death
this month i'm going to try to get a lot
of other video work done as well uh i i
need to do some core concept videos to
wrap up the uh
the discussions about aristotelian
virtues so
that's probably going to be about
another
five or six maybe seven core concept
videos uh because i haven't done that
many of those
and i'm doing that primarily for my my
online students um
they they can you know use these to help
them
understand the material that they're
grappling with in the ethics class if i
have the time i'm going to do some more
on jon stewart mill as well
i managed to get a few done this
semester but i need to do some some
additional ones on
his work utilitarianism
um
i've still got that aristotle categories
video hanging out there i did books one
through four
and i'm thinking that it'll be about
another
three or four videos to get through the
the totality of the categories
so i want to do that this month because
that's that's a very important text that
a lot of students struggle with
particularly because they get assigned
that text when probably they shouldn't
it's it's not really an introductory
text but a lot of people treat it as
that for
studying aristotle's
philosophy
so i'm going to try to get that finished
if i have the time i'll shoot a few more
personal videos
probably you know some of those
philosophical development ones about
phases i've gone through or philosophers
who i particularly like
um
i'm going to keep doing these philoso
geek
uh reflections and
i have a few other things i want to do
in terms of philosophy and current
events i did that one on the con
shooting count related shooting a while
back
there's a few other things in the news
these days
that i i think are connected
you know with philosophy to some degree
or philosophy can illuminate so i'm
going to do some videos on those
and what else have i got going on i'm
going to be finally putting together
some some curious lessons
i'm going to start with plato's apology
and that's probably going to be several
different lessons i've got some some
previous ones on sart up on curious
but i haven't done that much with with
that
and i would have liked to this fall but
i just didn't didn't find the time
and i'm going to be putting a lot more
stuff on learners
there's a few other things with my
online
presence that i want to tidy up here and
there with uh posting some things in
academia.edu or on linkedin
and
i want to get some writing done this
month that might be kind of a tall order
but i want to get some writing some more
writing done on aristotle and anger
the only way to get a book written is to
actually keep plowing away at it
i've got a few other
sketches for for book projects that i
want to put some flesh on
and think about maybe some shorter term
projects along those lines
and i'm going to start working on a
paper on descartes
and descartes views on on ethics which
is something that isn't talked about an
awful lot most people talk about
descartes in terms of epistemology or
metaphysics
and teaching
the
princess elizabeth correspondents and
the passions of the soul this semester
made me think an awful lot about
descartes views
on ethics and the good life and so i
want to do a paper
i have a conference in mind already
that i'll be submitting that one too
and what else am i doing i've got you
know this is a good time for me to get
get some reading done as well
and the two main things besides you know
like the heidegger and kierkegaard that
i'm rereading
i'm reading something new
somebody sent me
a colleague sent me some latin works by
this guy charles de beauvel who's a
renaissance philosopher
and
i'm reading a book of his called the
libra danilo the book literally the book
on nothing or the book about nothing
and it's some really interesting
metaphysics and i've got a i've got a
fascination with this this question of
negativity and nothingness and what
exactly is it you know what what is
privation what is um
negation
though those sorts of things and
eventually down the line i want to write
a book on it so
reading this guy charlotte level should
be very interesting
it's it's some slow
slow reading because it is in latin and
um
the
the punctuation has not been
um
modernized and so it takes a little bit
of time to figure out exactly how to
deconstruct and then reconstruct the
sentences
and i'm also um
other than you know things i'm reading
for for pleasure like reading philip k
dick stories or you know evelynoir or
things like that which really i
shouldn't spend as much time on as i do
my my other big commitment is to try to
this month
reread my way through the the whole of
hegel's phenomenology
in part because not this coming month
but come january
i want to start doing a
series of video lectures through youtube
specifically on hegel's phenomenology
and it might take quite a few
because what i'm planning on doing
is
just shooting
with me and the chalkboard
and and the
hegel's book
and going through each of the
developments
that
that he's charting out
and taking as long as it is actually
needed to to focus in and go through all
of that
so
um
it's kind of a big task
what i'm doing this this month is just
the preparatory rereading
for it um
you know i read hegel every so often
anyway but i haven't sat down and like
gone through the whole thing
which really you ought to do once in a
while with hegel
i haven't done that for for a while so
so that'll be kind of kind of fun i
think
kind of frustrating in parts as well
where he's quite opaque uh but but it's
rewarding to to work your way through
through this stuff
so that is what is going on uh this
month that's what i've been up to last
month once again let me put in a
uh plug about the
the the hangout on air
uh where i'll be talking with viewers
and uh
followers about
socrates and answering questions and
engaging in discussion and we'll see how
that goes